à augusta lunardi journaliste
indépendant bonsoir madame merci d'être
avec nous tout d'abord un mot sur cette
situation sanitaire du brésil quelle est
elle alors le bilan sanitaire s'est
beaucoup alourdi ces dernières semaines
et le brésil comptent davantage de
victimes du corps on a vu ce que la
chine et l'italie soit plus de 160 à
10000 personnes infectées par le col et
sachant que nous n'avons toujours pas
atteint le pic de de la maladie qui est
prévue seulement pour le mois de juillet
mais il est difficile à croire à ces
chiffres officiels car nous n'avons pas
assez de test dans le pays et selon les
chercheurs brésiliens
le nombre de personnes infectées serait
plus d'un million de cas donc la
situation est d'autant plus inquiétante
que les services publics de santé sont
désormais à déborder dans plusieurs
grandes villes du pays comme à rio ou
alors dans la région nord-est ou encore
dans la région de l'amazonie et même si
la courbe de victimes ça n'arrête pas de
grimper à depuis quelques semaines on
aperçoit de plus en plus de personnes
dans la rue et on les personnes
respectent de moins en moins les mesures
de confinement
alors j'ai un robot et sonar au louis ne
semble pas prendre la mesure de la crise
c'est bien ça oui exactement et continue
de nier la gravité de la situation et
continue de refuser d'instaurer un 1-1
confinement complet dans le pays et ces
dernières semaines il a il s'est offert
deux bandes de foule il a dit plusieurs
fois que la crise ferait plus de mal à
la poche du pays qu'est la santé des
brésiliens comment justement réagissent
ces derniers les brésiliens face à ces
propos de leur président alors il y a
trois le brésil a divisé en trois
parties un 3e quart il y a une grande
partie de la population qui suit les pas
de bol sonar ou quoi qu'il dise alors
que le pays est en plein chaos sanitaire
donc un tiers de la population continue
de nier la gravité ou alors même de 10
le virus n'existe pas et il reste fidèle
à tous que molson à roddy pour d'autres
le plus important c'est de rouvrir les
commerces parce que la plupart des
brésiliens 40 millions de brésiliens
pardon independent du commerce informel
donc ils se sont retrouvés sans travail
du jour au lendemain et il ne s'inquiète
pas tant que ça de la maladie et une
troisième partie de la population
extrêmement inquiète ces personnes-là
respecte le confinement instauré par les
gouverneurs et craignent une vraie
hécatombe dans le dans les prochaines
semaines car ils voient que le pays est
complètement dans un air plonger
complètement dans un dans un chaos
sanitaires et sociales on sait que le
pays le brésil est un pays pauvre
quelles sont les conséquences
économiques sur place y at il tout de
même certaines aides de l'état
mais exactement il y a eu une aide
établi par l'état 200 e rose qui est
très très peu car le coût de vie au
brésil est très très très élevé et cette
aide n'a pas aidé toute la population
brésilienne défavorisés 17 millions de
personnes sont toujours à la tante de
cette aide qui n'est toujours pas arrivé
et n'ont toujours pas vu cet argent sur
leurs comptes bancaires
est-ce qu'il ya très inquiet parce que
plus de 10 millions de personnes et ça
nous avons déjà 10 millions de
brésiliens ont perdu leur emploi à cause
de la crise donc la plupart comme disait
le le prêtre dans le sujet juste avant
cela va creuser les inégalités sociales
et la pauvreté le taux de chômage etc
on a entendu le discours de dissolution
du congrès également le soutien du
président brésilien des manifestations
pro dictature est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que j'aille humble sonar ou
à des tentations autoritaires
oui exactement 1 bolton araud a depuis
plusieurs semaines a pris l'habitude de
participer à des manifestations qui
prône la suppression du congrès la
suppression aussi de la cour suprême et
qui demandent une intervention militaire
où les participants réclament tosti une
application dès la 5 c'est un des
décrets le plus dur de la dictature
brésilienne et ces rassemblements lors
de ces rassemblements pardon golden
arrow a proclamé des phrases
très inquiétante comme la constitution 1
c'est moi ou alors les forces armées
sont à côté de la population brésilienne
et donc même si l'armée avait jamais dit
officiellement que son rattachement à
exprimer par dont son attachement
profond à la démocratie et à la liberté
les politologues brésiliens se sont
démontrés très très inquiet ces
dernières semaines et ils craignent un
processus d'érosion de la démocratie au
brésil merci à costa do mardi d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france